Problem 100.
They draw this graph, which I
guess I should also draw.
So they draw it pretty big.
So I'll draw it pretty
big as well.
They have a line that goes from
the center to there, it's
a pie graph.
Then they call that category
like that, and another
category that looks something
like that, and then they have
a final category that looks
something like that.
They say that this is
the highway trust
fund, which is 72%.
They say x% is a tire tax.
This is 12%, which
is a gas tax.
Then you have x plus 4%, which
is a tax on trucks.
According to the graph above,
what percent of the funds for
highway maintenance-- oh, and
this title says sources of
funds for highway maintenance.
So that's what this
whole thing is.
According to the graph above,
what percent of the funds for
highway maintenance came
from the tax on tires?
So we need to solve for x.
So let's think about it.
x plus 12 plus x plus 4, that's
this, plus 72 have to
equal 100%.
We have two x's, get those out
of the way, and then what is
this equal to?
12 plus 4 is 16.
16 plus 72-- let me
write that down.
I always make careless
mistakes.
That's 16.
16 plus 72 is 88.
2x plus 88 is equal to 100.
Then you have 2x is equal
to, subtract 88
from both sides, 12.
x is equal to 6.
That's exactly what we're
looking for, the tire tax.
So that's 6%.
That's choice B.
Drawing it was harder
than solving it.
Problem 101.
A poll reveals that the average
arithmetic mean income
of 10 households is $25,000.
So we could say, average
of 10 is equal to 25K.
If 6 of the households have
income of $30,000 each, what
is the average of the
other 4 households?
So if we were to average all of
them, we could say it would
be 6 times the households that
are 30,000, so 6 times 30K,
plus 4 times the average
of the other 4.
So let's say that's what we're
trying to solve for, 4 times
the average of the other
4 households.
This would be the sum of
all of the households.
If we were to divide that by
10, we're going to get the
total average of all
10, which is 25.
Hopefully that makes sense.
You have 6 households making
30K, so the sum of those
households is going
to be 6 times 30.
Then the sum of the other 4
households is going to be 4
times their average.
That's what they're asking
us for, what
is the average income?
If you take the sum of all the
households, all 10, you divide
it by 10, you get
their average.
So you get 6 times 30-- I don't
want to make this look
like a variable,
that's 30,000.
We know we're dealing
in thousands.
So 6 times 30 is 180 plus 4x
is equal to 10 times 25, is
equal to 250.
4x is equal to, what's
250 minus 180?
That's 50, and you have another
20, it's equal to 70.
Then you have x is equal to,
let's see, 4 goes into 70,
130, goes into it 7,
7 times 4 is 28.
Goes into 20 5 times,
and the decimal.
So 17.5, and we're dealing with
thousands, so $17,500.
That's choice C.
Problem 102.
If T is equal to 5/9 times K
minus 32, and T is equal to
290, then what is K equal to?
This is kind of one of
those speed problems.
So we have 290 is equal to
5/9 times K minus 32.
So multiply both sides by 9/5,
you get 9/5 times 290 is equal
to K minus 32.
So what's 290 divided by 5?
5 goes into 29 5 times,
25, 40, 58 times.
So it's 9 times 58 is
equal to K minus 32.
58 times 9, 8 times 9 is 72.
5 times 9 is 45 plus 7 is 52.
522.
So 522 is equal to K minus 32.
So K is equal to 522 plus 32,
which is equal to 554, Which
is choice D.
After doing all that math, I
was afraid that I'd made a
careless mistake.
But it's reassuring
to see that 554
is one of the choices.
Problem 103.
The water from one outlet
flowing at a constant rate can
fill a swimming pool
in 9 hours.
So you could say 1 pool per
9 hours from 1 outlet.
The water from a second outlet
flowing at a constant rate can
fill the same pool in 5 hours.
So 1 pool in 5 hours, that's
the second one.
If both outlets are used at the
same time, approximately
what is the number of hours
required to fill the pool?
So essentially, we can just
add their two rates.
This one does 1/9 pool per hour,
plus 1/5 pool per hour.
I just rewrote those two.
So what's 1/9 plus 1/5?
Let's find a common
denominator.
45 I think is the first
common denominator.
1/9 is 5 over 45.
1/5 is 9 over 45.
So together, they fill 5 plus
9 is 14/45 pool per hour.
If you want to fill exactly
1 pool, so it's just like
production is equal to
rate times time.
So now your production is, you
want to fill 1 pool, and you
can fill it at 14 over
45 pools per
hour, what is the time?
Well the time is going to be
equal to 1/1 pool divided by
14/45 pools per hour, which is
equal to, 45/14-- 1 over a
fraction is just the
inverse of that
fraction-- so 45/14 hours.
How many times does
14 going into 45?
14 goes into 45,
is it 3 times?
3 times 14 is 12, is 42.
Then you have another 30.
Well, I already see one of the
choices, 3 point something.
But 14 goes into 30 2 times.
2 times 14 is 28.
Let's see if one of our choices
is already-- yes,
choice D is already close
enough to what we did.
We don't have to do
any more math.
So we get 3.2 hours.
If we'd kept dividing,
we'd get 3.21.
That's choice D.
It's just a little confusing.
The important thing
is to always get
it in terms of rate.
Add the rate, and just remember
distance is equal to
rate times time, or production
is equal to rate times time.
Don't let all these fractions
daunt you too much.
Next problem.
I'm almost out of space.
Problem 104.
Diana bought a stereo for $530,
which was the retail
price, plus a 6% sales tax.
So that is equal to 1.06 times
the retail, 6% percent more
than the retail.
How much could she have saved
if she had bought the stereo
at the same retail price in a
neighboring state, where she
would have paid a
sales tax of 5%?
So essentially we want to
figure out how much she
would've saved.
So let's figure out what
the retail price was.
So retail is equal to
530 divided by 1.06.
1.06 goes into 530, it's a
decimal, add two 0's, shift
the decimal over to
the right twice.
106 goes into it
5 times, right?
106 goes into 530 5 times.
5 times 106, it's 530.
OK, so the math here
was simple.
so you have two 0's.
So the retail price is $500.
So she paid $30 in
tax, fair enough.
If she went to the neighboring
state and paid 5%, how much
would she have paid in taxes?
So times 0.05, 5 times 5, well 5
times 500 is 2,500, plus two
decimals, so it's $25 in tax.
So in the neighboring
state, she
would've paid $25 in taxes.
She paid $30 in taxes.
So she would have saved $5.
So the choice is D.
Let's just try to fit one more
problem in here, just so we
finish this page.
They say, if a square mirror has
a 20 inch diagonal, what
was the approximate perimeter
of the mirror in inches?
Let's try to do that.
That's not what I want to do.
I have a square mirror,
it has a diagonal.
That diagonal, they're telling
us, is 20 inches.
It's a square, so all the
sides are the same.
They want to know
its perimeter.
So they want to know essentially
what 4x is equal
to if we add up all the sides.
So what is x?
Well we just use Pythagorean
theorem.
This is a right angle.
So we know that x squared plus
x squared is equal to 20
squared, is equal to
the hypotenuse
squared, is equal to 400.
2x squared is equal to 400.
x squared is equal to 200.
x is equal to the square
root of 200.
They want to know
the perimeter.
Well, it's going to
be 4 times that.
So the perimeter is going to be
equal to 4 times the square
root of 200.
Now this becomes an
approximation problem.
So let's think about that.
The square root of
200 is about 15.
15 times 15 is 225.
Yeah, I think 15 would be a
pretty good approximation.
14 would also work.
14, when you square
it, is 196.
14 times 14, 4 times 16 is 56.
Then you have 140.
So 14 is about as close as
you're going to get to 200.
It's going to be someplace
between 14 and 15.
So 14 times 4 is 40.
So 4 times 4 is 16, it's 56.
So it's going to be something
higher than 56.
If we pick 14, it's 56.
If we pick 15, it's 60.
So someplace between 56 and 60
is going to be the perimeter
of that mirror.
So it's one of the
choices B, 60.
So that's going to be
the closest one.
So I'd go with B.
I'll see you in the
next video.